Okay.
So what I'm thinking here
looking our possible inputs.
If we were to take none or
an empty matrix as an input.
We would return zero.
Because for sure there would
be no islands in this case.
But we could also have this as an input.
So what I'm thinking here,
is we start at the first element.
That's a one.
So, I'll probably want some sort
of island counter variable and
I'll initialize that there and
increment it by one.
And then I get to the zero.
And that's not part of any islands.
So, I don't need to
do anything there and
I get to this next element right here.
So, that's actually part
of the same island.
So I need to keep track of what
ones are part of the same island.
Maybe what I could do is I could
look at the elements on top, and
on bottom, and then check if
they're part of the same island.
And then keep track of it somehow.
Yeah that sthird approach but if you're
looking at that first element for
example there is another one below
it but there's nothing above it.
So what would you do in that case??
>> All right because since there
is not a one above that we'd
probably get some sort of runtime error.
So first I would want to make sure
to check that there's actually
an element there before I
check if it's a one or a zero.
So I'm going to need to
keep track of this somehow.
Maybe this is some
sort of data structure.
>> Yeah, does this approach or
the problem or
anything you've been walking through
your remind you of anything?
>> Yeah, since this matrix can sort
of be like represented as a graph.
This might be a breath
first search problem.
So what I could do is when
I find the first one,
I can look at the elements around it and
I can add those elements to Q.
Check if those are ones and then if
they're are ones I could set them to
another number so
they're marked as visited.
And then I could keep going.
>> Yeah that sounds really great.
>> So it looks like his test cases
came in handy when brainstorming
his solution.
>> Sure did.
>> He was able to use test cases to inch
his way towards developing a solution.
Something else I noticed was that
he had great communication with
the interviewer.
He took the interviewer's cues to guide
him towards the correct solution.
>> Yeah a big misconception that future
interviewees can have is they think that
their interviewer isn't on their side.
But really the interviewer
is there to help you and
being able to take in their feedback
demonstrates your teamwork skills.
Not to mention it helps
you solve the problem.
Sometimes in an interviewee might get so
nervous that he or
she just completely ignores
the interviewer's suggestions.
This can be a big turn off for
the interviewers.
So what if the interviewee was still
stuck after looking at his test cases
and edge cases?
>> Well, one thing the interviewee
mentioned was that this problem reminded
him of the breath for
a search algorithm.
Often if an interviewees is stuck
on a certain portion of the problem
they can begin to brainstorm
algorithms and data structures.
The interviewee may have noticed that a
graph can be represented as a matrix and
that a breath first search
algorithm would fit here.